our game of the month for februari
celebrates the time-honored Valentine's
tradition of getting together with the
ones you love and completely destroying
some disgusting larger-than-life
creatures of course I'm talking about
Monster Hunter 4 ultimate that's not to
say we didn't have some other great
experiences as well the beautiful
platforming adventure grow home provided
a lot of world to explore and the
multiplayer I'd I've had the most robust
character customization options as well
as a way to play with friends both
competitively on the game screen or by
letting them affect your experience
through social media and the months
either monster hunting adventure evolve
has a great pedigree coming from the
creators of left 4 dead distinct
memorable characters frightening cook
boolean beasts and the chance to play as
the monster in for v1 matches is an
exciting evolution of the group versus
group dynamic from left 4 dead but
monster hunter for ultimate came out on
top as the series monster Honda has
always been ridiculously successful in
Japan but none of the games have ever
caught on in the rest of the world for
ultimate has the most potential to
change that the on ramp to getting into
the game learning how the items and
systems work and fighting larger than
life beasts is faster than ever for
experienced players the game's new
weapons are a particularly exciting
addition the insect glaive takes
advantage of the newly added ability to
jump in the game letting you leave
freely on two monsters backs or out of
harm's way and the charge blade is a
weapon that changes form mixing the
speed of a sword with the stopping power
of a heavy axe that's not even touching
on MH for use wonderfully fun filled
localization custom pellicer companions
and robust array of customizable armors
februari gives you two great ways to
hunt monsters with your friends but
Monster Hunters cast
ization options and hundreds of hours of
content make in the game that you won't
be playing just for now you're going to
be playing it all year